The answer is that L is not
recognizable, but L complement is.
Note that there are some Turing
machines that accept nothing
that we can tell accept nothing.
We can examine the code, for instance
of the Turing machine that immediately
transitions to the reject
state no matter what.
And we can see that such a Turing
machine never accepts anything.
But it's not clear that we
can do that in general.
On the other hand, it turns out
that we can recognize L complement,
the set of Turing machines
that accept something.
We just run the Turing machine on all
strings and see if accepts any of them.
Now, if you answered no here because
you thought of this possibility, but
were worried that some of these
computations might not halt and
that that would ruin it,
then actually good for you.
It shows that you're thinking carefully.
This is a real problem, because we can't
just run M on the empty string, and
then run it on the zero string,
and so forth.
The computation on the empty
string might never halt.
The solution is essentially to run
all these computations in parallel.
Note that this is challenging, but
it can be done through
a strategy called dovetailing.